l'oin foil c'est le petit nouveau de la
semaine nautique un petit bleu qui ne
devrait pas le rester très d'entente il
est spectaculaire et adaptés aux
conditions de vent reçu cette semaine
quoique à la moindre baisse de vigilance
c'est la sanction assurer le plus
expérimenté sur cette compétition c'est
thomas le kent après des années en
planche à voile et plusieurs semaines de
schelcher il y fait un come back
tonitruant vainqueur dès dimanche et
disputé
à l'époque c'était la formula
windsurfing donc ça reste quand même des
grosses planches avec des grosses voile
mais c'est vrai que là maintenant on a
un fol donc ça permet de naviguer au
dessus de l'eau honte à être un peu
comme un oiseau en liberté on va dire et
cela offre d'excellentes sensations donc
c'est ça fait plaisir dix ans plus tard
pour moi en tous cas me concernant
revivre la semaine nautique de
schoelcher sur un autre support
du coup ils sont huit à s'essayer issus
des différentes celle de la martinique
de la thune le vauclin le yacht-club
chercheur et un de la guadeloupe à 42
ans jean le sulky à 30 ans de planche à
voile derrière lui mais à peine six mois
de fouilles volé à un mètre au-dessus de
l'eau lui apporte de nouvelles
sensations
[Musique]
apprendre à gérer son flotteur ils sont
gourmands
donc sachant qu'on sort de la planche à
voile ce n'est vraiment pas les mêmes
automatise alors au niveau international
ils sont quand même pas loin de 30
noeuds ce qui fait près 60 kilomètres
heure
ici on est dans les 27 noeuds
[Musique]
pour terminer le podium on retrouve marc
vds il s'était fait connaître à 17 ans
en 2015 pour son tour de la martinique
en planches vous plaît en 14h35
l'endurance il connaît les avec ce vent
en rafales qui fait lever la mer c'est
une autre technique faut rester attentif
à chaque instant pour éviter tout faux
mouvement et pour éviter de tomber à
l'eau et c'est vraiment le fait d'être à
fond faire gaffe à tout ce qu'on fait
tout le temps pendant toute la manche
qui est vraiment épuisant
[Musique]
nous
c'est magnifique ça va ça glisse ça fait
pas de bruit